um this is a huge night for you tonight
yeah i get to co-host with dolly parton
and gabby barrett it's pretty crazy okay
so i want some behind-the-scenes gossip
what's it been like working up close
with dolly like that it's been great
she's funny
and she's a good she's a real person and
she's really good at just
reminding you that she's a human you
know and she treats everybody the same
it's just been great hanging out with
her i've been star struck the whole time
oh i can only imagine so nominated
you're co-hosting you're performing can
you talk about your performance tonight
because i know it's a beautiful tribute
to your father yeah so uh i get to
perform a new song i wrote about my dad
it's all called down home
uh yes about you know me and my siblings
missing them which they were still here
and it's cool i get to sing that song
on my mom's birthday and my mom's here
tonight so uh
yeah it's uh it's gonna be fun i'm
looking forward to the world hearing it
it means a lot is your mom a ball of
nerves right now or is she excited oh
she's excited yeah for sure yeah said oh
my god listen this is a huge night for
you favorite dolly song though
well
i like the my favorite dolly song is the
one she wrote i will always love you
that that song is just
it's it's a it's that's my top five
songs of all time yeah so i gotta say
that one absolutely yeah then you got
working on the five you got yeah yeah
yeah it's a lot and just because no
one's wrapping me quite yet so i'm gonna
i'm gonna get one more question there
male artist of the year what does that
mean to you being nominated i'm trying
to figure out how i got in that category
with all these other
guys with five six seven eight nine ten
twelve number ones torn arenas man i'm
not even doing arenas yet i'm one i'm
just grateful for the nomination
i guess it means that over the last year
i've
with the help of my team
and and the fans i've been able to place
myself in positions where i could
represent country music on a mass scale
so i'm just honored to be nominated and
it feels crazy listen enjoy tonight this
is your night
so nice meeting you